welcome to our cell culture seminar
my name is marina viklander and i'm a
field marketing specialist for cell
culture portfolio in western europe
during our seminar we will provide you
with tips and tricks
on how to culture your cell lines
troubleshooting your cell culture
in order to achieve reliable and
reproducible source of data
first of all we would like to give you
introduction into the cell
culture and provide with some important
historical events
from historical perspective a number of
important development
led us to the current state of the
research here we would like to mention
only some of them the first time word
cell
appeared in a book microglia written by
robert hooke already in 1665
please take in consideration that the
first cell line
was discovered only in 1952
harry eagle was the first american
physician and pathologist
who established the first media very
famous currently
on the market as the eagles minimum
essential media
in 1955. everyone of course remembered
dr
james thompson him and his group in 1998
were the first ones who isolated the
first human pluripotent stem cells
and they didn't just isolate it they
were also able
to differentiate them in the three
german lines
fast forward to eight years later to
2006 to shinier yamanaka
and his discovery of four
transcriptional factors
that play a key role in reprogramming
somatic cells
to deploy report on sales you all know
that he won a nobel prize
making his that work also quite
recently you can consider it quite
recently around 2010
the 3d cell cultures were brought also
into world of cell culture so what is
next
there is probably some more things to
come
so what is a cell culture and what is
the objective
basically cell culture are the cells
grown outside of their natural
environment
in a controlled condition we all know
that
the cell culture is absolutely essential
in the research
it has helped us to understand the
complex cellular physiology
on how cells function and respond to
stimuli
understand biological processes in order
to prevent
diagnose and treat the diseases
looking at the cell culture workflow
let's look at it from experimental
perspective when you're ready to prepare
cells for an assay or experiment
the first thing you will do is sort out
an existent stock of cells
that are cryopreserved once you seeded
the cells and they recovered
we enter to this routine part of the
cell culture
this is where eu researchers will spend
a lot of time
feeding the cells monitoring certain
parameters such as confluency
the ph of the media morphology
cell density and many other factors
you also have an opportunity here to
subculture
or passage the cells when they're grown
and expanded
you may split off part of your cell
culture and expand for experimental
purposes
you may want to manipulate cells in by
adding some potential therapeutic drugs
and measured in effect on the cells by
running an
assay transfect transfected with the
gene of
interest or any other manipulation
all will be later used to
to analyze dependent on the goal of the
study
also if you go back a little bit to step
two
you may also want to cryopreserve your
cells
so you can have a stock frozen stock
for later on use
in order to produce reliable and
consistent data
make sure that your lab and all your
colleagues
follow the good cell culture techniques
only in that case
nothing can affect your data make sure
that you follow the
aseptic technique and all your personnel
as well as equipment are sterilized
and sterile and that includes not only
the laminal hood but that you wear the
sterile gloves
you wear laboratory coats and all the
other needed equipment
also ever since you grow the cell saying
whether it's
pipettes or cell culture vessels needs
to be sterilized
and protected from any kind of infection
and contamination now we would like to
talk about
your cells what are you planning to
choose what type of cells you're
planning to select
for your experiments
once you decided on your experiments you
need to choose what type of cell lines
you would be working with and it is very
important step
before you order any kind of media
growth factors or supplements
because only the type of cells will
determine
all the rest reagents you can work with
the primary cells
they are usually isolated from the
patient tissue
or healthy individual and way more
biologically relevant
however they do have also the
limitations it's more difficult to grow
the primary cell lines and also they
have a short life span
for about five to six passages after
that you would
you would need to acquire new cells
cell lines or as we call them
immortalized cells
can be cultured for very very long time
very consistent source of cells and
pretty easy to modify
as well however they also do have a
limitation
they are not as biologically relevant as
the primary cells
or the stem cells they do have a
genetic drift and also authenticity
might be a really in question here so
take that in consideration as well stem
cells
currently considered the most
biologically relevant source for studies
not so easy to work with however
they're really potentially used for
for gene editing and other manipulations
as well
if you decided to choose immortalized
cell line
make sure that they are biologically
relevant to your model as i mentioned
previously immortalized cell line have a
tendency for the genetic drift
you can order the first genetic material
either
dna rna or cdna and make a screening for
the gene of your interest
here is an example for androgen receptor
screening
researchers previously previously used
thp1
ducap cell lines and wanted to know if
the receptor was expressed in other
lymphoblasts monocytes and hepatic cell
lines
the test was performed on 15 ecaxel
lines
and as you can see in this experiment in
a
in a pcr nine out of 15
contained androgen receptor
researchers decided to dig a little bit
deeper in order
to identify the expression level of of
the androgen receptor
using quantitative rt pcr and based on
that results they could confirm
that four cell lines indeed had an
expression
of androgen receptor and they could use
them in their research
it is very important to go through the
screening process
before you acquire the new cell line
that ensures that this cell line
is actually relevant for your essay
if you decided to work with immortalized
cell line and as i previously mentioned
the cell authenticity can be really an
issue
you remember i mentioned that the cell
line culture starts
from 1952 when the first cell line
called the hela cell line which takes
the name
after the patient henrietta lux was
established in john hopkins memorial
hospital
since that moment there was like an
explosion
of discoveries of cell cultures and you
probably heard the story as well
that there was a lot of heli infection
or contamination by hela cell line will
identify
later on in a lot of cell cultures
please be aware of that
as it's been estimated that
approximately 10 to 20 percent of the
cell lines
are contaminated with hela cell line but
it's not only healer which is a problem
there can be other cross contamination
and misi
identify cell lines
due to this problem with with
contamination and
misidentification of the cell lines
several guidelines for the cell line
notification
has been put in place and has been
supported by iclick
and nih and a lot of publishing groups
for example as a nature publishing group
have now
guidelines when you submitting the paper
it is absolutely required
to provide identification of the cell
line
you've been using for your experiments
so what are the most common cause for
cross-contamination
or misidentified cells one of the
reasons can be
intentional inoculation of a regional
cell line
with invasive cell line and that very
often happens when
researchers are working with several
lines at the same time
and i know with our research it's very
difficult to work with one cell line
but at least when you're doing media
change or when you do
any kind of manipulation with cells we
would strongly recommend you
to work with one cell line at a time and
try to clean the surface
in between the different cell lines the
handling of pipette is very important as
well as
any other reagents which are around you
do strongly recommend to have a
dedicated media re-engines
and any other supplements for the single
cell line
at the time to prevent from any type of
cross-contamination another reason can
be as well
as we all know and we work in the lab
and we meet someone during a coffee
break to find out that they're working
with a cell line which might be
interested for you
it is very nice to have a nice
environment in the lab
however when you acquire the cell line
from
from your friends colleagues or any
other other collaborators
it is very important to make sure that
you authenticate the cells
before you start experiments because it
might be that something went wrong
in della in their lab so in general we
we recommend that it's way more safe for
you
and for your research to acquire the
cells from the
cell bank repository like ecac for
example
but if it's not possible if you really
want to use
your collaborators please do
authentication
before you do the experiments
the mislabeling of the cryovials or
even the cultural vessels can lead also
to misensification
and cross-contamination as well make
sure that all your vials
all your cell culture lab where
is properly marked and it comes also to
the
as i mentioned previously to dedicated
media and reagents as well
so you don't have any chances of
cross contaminating between different
cell lines
and last and not least also as i
mentioned previously
if you're working with immortalized
cells the genetic drift if you can
continuously passage in the cells might
occur so if you suddenly realizing that
the genetic
level or the morphology of the cells
change a lot compared to the cells
you were culturing a year ago it might
be the reason
so you have to create a master cell bank
and then create from the master cell
bank of working cell bank
to make sure that all your cells are
exactly at the same pathogen level
to preserve the cells from any genetic
drift
cell authentication as i mentioned
before is a
very very big part an important part in
in cell
culturing as i said already a lot of
journals as well as
a lot of grant applications require
if you're working with immortalized
cells to authenticate the cells
to make sure that all in all your
experiments
the cells you started working with if
you done during
during process any manipulation and at
the end exactly
from the same origin the cell
authentication is done by
str profiling which stands for the short
tandem repeats
and as you probably know it's
international reference standard
for this human cell line here in the
image you can see how the str profiling
looks like
str's uh repeated regions of dna found
throughout human genome
and they're really they have really high
variability
between individuals
if you're capable of doing this in your
labs
you're more than welcome doing that it's
not a very difficult
experiment however it might be quite
difficult to
read the str profile so in that case
we recommend you if it's possible to
send yourselves for example to the
repositories like ecac
and they can do this uh this service
for you and give you a results back
however try to keep it in mind it is
very important
to keep the cell identification under
control
long-term pathogen can lead to a genetic
drift and as well abnormalities in a
chromosome
so it is very important to run the test
to identify the genetic integrity and
stability
as you might know chromosomal changes
they might overtake the
entire culture and in that case you will
see
a lot of gross behavioral changes as
well as changes in morphology
and that can lead also to inaccurate
results
as i mentioned it is a possibility that
you will see a
big genomic big changes between
behavior yourself from now and
one year ago in the next part we want to
look
what else can affect your cell so we
talk about
how important it is to choose the right
cell line
how important it is to i to make sure
that your cell
is authenticated and there is no cross
contamination
because it can really affect the results
of your experiments
now let's look at other reagents
in your in your cell culture which can
really
affect the cell growth
as we talk from the beginning cell
culture are the cells which are growing
outside of their natural environment so
it is very important
to create the right environment for the
cell cultures
so they feel comfortable they grow and
provide us with valuable
and reliable information now that we
choose the right cells
i would recommend that you acquire them
from
reputable source like ecac to make sure
that they're authenticated and clean and
have no
any contamination the next step is to
acquire
all the medias and supplements which are
necessary
in order to grow the cells as you know
cell culture media provides nutrition
and provides asthmatic balance and also
maintain the proper ph
there are a number of classical medias
and special medias dependent on the
cells you will be
working with it's not a secret you can
easily go on
any repository or even our website
and see what type of media needed
specifically for your
cell type and also which other
supplements
needed in order to add to cells so they
can grow
as happy as possible please order all
your cells
and media and regions before
you soar your cells so everything is
ready for you
fbs is also very important it delivers
nutrients and growth factors and
attachment factors
so you need to add those in the right
concentration
there are other supplements like
glutamine
hepas antibiotics we're not really
recommend to use antibiotics however
some medias there absolutely acquires
that
and also there is a number of growth
factors which you needed in order for
the cells to feel
happy if you need any more information
or
any products from this please
look at our website and i will try to
help you as much as possible
once growing your cell it is very
important to keep yourself in
physiological conditions
and ph is one of a very important
elements
as you know phenol red is added into
cell culture media
to indicate the ph level the normal
range of ph level is between 7.2 to 7.4
and it's controlled by uh different
parts by buffering system like
bicarbonate
but it's also controlled by co2 level in
your cell culture incubator
so if we look at this image for example
if you
if you see that these cells are still
made suddenly turn
so yellow it means that the ph will
will be very low due to release of
lactic acid and it means that
the media needs to be changed
immediately
if you have between 7.07.4 as you can
see here
it's a it's a red seven point five four
it's a red this is what you see in the
battles
what you see on the second at is
seven point zero this is something you
can see already that
the media started them turning a little
bit yellow
it's still safe to keep cells in that
media as well
however probably tomorrow you would need
to change the media already there
and if we look at the last one at 7.8
you can see that the high ph may
indicate
that there is a very high level of
ammonia from glutamine
or there is a some changes in the co2
levels in your incubator so
maybe this is a time for you to change
to check
if everything is okay with your
incubator
make sure that your cells feel
comfortable that
it's the temperature in the incubator is
optimal as you know
the optimal temperature for the
mammalian cells is 37 degrees
i just previously mentioned the the co2
level is also very important and in that
case you will see the changes in the
color of the media
here is an example uh as you can see
below
when the temperature in the incubator
was wrong
if you wonder on the first image with a
little bit like reddish color
what does it look like it's actually
looks like a
metal bars in the incubator
you can see that it was so cold in an
incubator that the cells were hiding
on those metal bars and the second
image which is a little bit bluish you
can see it's exactly the opposite
reaction
it was so hot in the incubator that the
cells were trying to hide
in between those metal bars so
try to avoid any kind of um
extreme temperatures or extreme co2s
make sure that you you controlling your
incubators as well
because when cells under stress you you
probably will get
also a wrong response from them when you
do
any kind of manipulations for your
essays later on
we have a different type of cells some
of them they're grown in suspension
some of them adherent cells it's very
important
to understand your cells to know
what your cells are needing and
therefore
choosing the right environment for them
some cases as you know as you see here
the research
the researchers grow in the cells
directly on the plastic
it's very inexpensive and it's
less sensitive cell lines such as
293 for example sometimes researchers
realizing that the cells do not feel so
comfortable and they need a little bit
more help
in order to grow in order to divide
in this case researchers will pre-code
the cells which have some attachment
factors
such as collagen vibranctin or laminine
these two traditional to two-dimensional
cell culture
there is also possibility of growing the
cells
on the membranes as an example here we
have a hanon inserts we have a standing
in source
and in that case cells are growing on
membrane
and they will receive the media from the
bottom and from the top
and grow almost like in a in a 3d
environment
there are also possibility of growing
the cells in the 3d dimension as well
and this is something we talk in our
other presentation so if you would be
interested look at our
3d cell culture presentation
in that case it's more maybe can the
in vivo environment compared to the 2d
cell culture
and we do have a number of different
hydrogels which can help you
to achieve uh that level of growth
so now we selected the cell lines which
we need to work
with which are relevant for our research
we choose the media the supplements the
growth factors
we check that we all our incubator is
working well the temperature is correct
the co2 level is correct
we selected also whether we need to grow
the cells in suspension
or whether you use any attachment
factors or any kind of hydrogel
now is the first step in the growing
your cells
and the very important cells is to sow
the cells correctly
and it's very very important part so we
check the cell
line uh data sheet we need to prepare
the flask
it needs to be pre-warmed with already
growth factors and supplements
in it and then we
put the cells into the water bus
and we suggest to do it very fast at 37
degrees
and the reason to that because i hope
you remember that one of the components
for
in the cryo preservation is the dmso and
dmso
is very toxic also if you're working
with the stem cells it also leads to
differentiation
so it is very important to sow the cells
very fast in the water bars
and try not to use your hand or
to use an incubator what about doing it
fast
and easy pipette the cells into sterile
tube and slowly add pre-warmed media
it is very important step as well
especially for the suspension we
recommend after to use a centrifugation
to remove
any traces of dms or any traces of cryo
preservation
also as i mentioned because it if you're
working with the stem cells it can be
really important part
very important step for you because dmso
can differentiate can cause
differentiation of the stem cells so
do it do it fast do not spin
at a very high levels you remember you
spin it only at 150 g
so uh to remove the media
and after that you transfer into
appropriate volume
vessel to achieve desired density it is
also very important
to calculate your cells or to know how
many cells you have in the vials
so you add appropriate level of the
media
otherwise um they will eat up the
growth factors and supplements too fast
and you will see that the media will
change yellow
too fast you need to incubate it at
37 degrees and of course
examine your cells check yourselves that
they feel comfortable
after 24 hours if you see the poor
attachment of your
cells if you're working with adherent
cells
there might be reason to that there
might be that some there are some
factors which are preventing them from
attachment it might be either
contamination
or the some changes in in the
temperature or
co2 in your incubator so
all these things you need to take as a
sign that
something is disturbing the normal cell
grows
because the usual media serum and
supplement
they should help cells to attach as
dimensional so you can use
isis say as i said and extracellular
matrixes
or attachment factors like collagen
or fibronectin or laminine in order to
enhance attachment and growth of the
cells
use it as a control and you know
microplasma contamination is the cell
culture's
worst nightmare the reason to that
because we cannot see it with our naked
eye
microplasma is a very small bacteria
without the cell wall
and it means that even if you use an
antibiotics in your
cell culture you wouldn't be able to to
kill that bacteria it's really
a high range of survival that is why
it's very important
to keep all your medias and supplements
sterile
and all your hoods cleaned
to prevent from any contamination
mycoplasma may lead to
alteration of the in morphology or
in the cell grows it can cause also
chromosomal elaboration
and it might not but the major reason
major problem with microplasma
contamination that it will
always invalidate your results and as i
mentioned now
also for the journals if if you're
showing that you're working with a cell
culture or if you're applying for the
for the grant as well they will always
require your
test for microplasma contamination and
it can
really damage your reputation as well so
the testing is absolutely
required for the mycoplasma
contamination
there are a number of tests you can
apply
there is either cell culture isolation
or the pcr reaction
or the staining by a hurst so
try to do it during all your
research procedures to make sure quite
regularly maybe once a month or every
other week
to make sure that you do not have any
mycoplasma contamination
in your cells compared to microplasma
which you cannot see with a naked eye
there are other type of contaminations
which are pretty visible
such as bacteria yeast and fungi
if you see any kind of cloudness or you
can see that there is a
changes in ph uh always check it
on the microscope and make sure that you
do not have any contamination
if you do have a contamination or you're
not really sure
as we say when adapt just throw it out
don't do it don't use it to prevent
from any kind of contamination as i
mentioned
always work and buy a safety cabinet and
clean
uh disinfect all your
equipment which you work in user with
terra use sterile filtration from the
media for the reagents
make sure that everything is clean
around you
so if you rule out the contamination but
you still see the cloudness in your
media
it might be that it's precipitation of
some proteins
or other components in the media it can
be really
harmful for the cells and can be very
harmful for your
downstream application as well so it is
very important
to identify what causing this kind of
problems
it can be due to temperature shifts you
know the
freezing and sewing of the media can
lead to precipitation of the proteins
it might be that there is some water
loss as well
due to the evaporation so wrong
temperature in the wrong temperature and
incubator
can be effect of the calcium salts that
they will not properly dissolve
before added into media or it might be
that you added some
metal supplements and they can
precipitate as well
so make sure that you your media
is as perfect as possible to provide
the best environment for the cells
another issue we hear from the our
researchers is the clumpiness of the
cells
and it can really affect the results of
your experiments
because if the cells clamp too much they
don't have
such a good access to the critical
nutrients
and which can affect their overall
expression
as well as the cell growth so it is very
important to
analyze and understand your cells
and see how you can prevent from
companies
the cause of columbus can be different
either there's a cell lysis and dna
release and in that case you can add
dnase one
in order to prevent it in some type of
cells
it can be also due to bivalent cations
so in that and such as citrate and edta
can be
add to remove the extra calcium
which might come from from serum or
other balanced salts
cell density is also very important so
try to check some publications or
literature
what would be the recommended cell
density
and also the handling of the cells it is
very important to
use appropriate centrifugation settings
and also
gentle work with with some of the cells
as i mentioned during our sewing
procedure
that it is very important to count your
cells to know how many cells you have
in the vial and the reason to that that
we think that
it is very important to keep a growth
curve as internal control
as you can see on this growth curve
you see the logarithmic phase when the
cells are
doubling over time and then they come to
the stationary plateau
and eventually to the deaths why it is
important to know
the the cell grows curve the reason to
that that
you will be using those cells for your
application
and also you would want to freeze your
cells
for the for the future so if you need to
use those cells later on
they will be at their best and usually
the cells are collected at the end of
the logarithmic phase because this is
where you have most of the cells
very viable and in strong health
and not so many dead cells you would
hope for
another reason why you would do this the
curve as well
because cells are very consistent and if
they have a proper media
proper temperatures and all the rest
in order with all the supplements
the growth curve will be repeating
itself
and if you suddenly notice that the
cells started
growing poorly or opposite they start
growing too fast
or they're not so viable anymore it must
be it might be
that there is some kind of issues with
the cells diesel can be
contaminated as i mentioned microplasma
is not visible and you cannot see it
it might be that you have some issues
with an incubator
as i mentioned the temperature can be a
problem the
humidity level maybe there's some
vibration next to the
incubator as well it it might be also
that
something else is making yourselves
unhappy with the media or the
supplements
so the growth curve is a very very nice
internal control for you
now that we have our cells growing let's
look at the pathogen
and how important it is can be for your
for your applications and analysis
as i mentioned before it's quite easy to
passage the cell
if you know yourself gross curve will
give
will provide you with that information
and makes you will make your life easier
in the lab
so once you examine the cells identify
whether they're at 80 percent of their
confluency
that is usually should be at the end of
the logarithmic phase
as you know trypsin is an inactivated in
the presence of serum
so it is very important that you remove
all the
all media before you add trips in
wash it with pbs as well
then you need to detach the cells from
the vessel by adding trypsin
or any other detachment factors
which you would be using in your lab
resuspend in fresh media and then seed
the
the cells in the new vessel
trypsin is the most common reagent used
currently in the
in the labs however there are other
substitutes like
acumax as well there is an easy lift if
we are talking about the stem cells
so depending on your cell line you would
need to find the best reagent for your
cells
in that case you might required to test
them
to analyze them and see what works the
best for you
as i mentioned the trypsin protocol is
quite easy
you do need to remove first the media
because it will contain
the serum which will affect trypsin
otherwise
wash it with pbs add pre-warm trips in
please do not ban the plate
on the table just let it incubate for
two three minutes in the room
temperature
if it needed you can put it also in the
incubator if you see that it's a little
bit difficult for the cells to
detach and then once they detach
add pre-one media to neutralize trypsin
you can centrifuge the cells count them
check out their viability add the fresh
media
at the appropriate density and put them
in
in a fresh flask
i would like to stress it a little bit
more it is very important
to count your cells to analyze the
viability of your cells
because all your downstream applications
depend on that
on the quality of your cells
hemodesitometer
is one of the most common use method for
counting in this case you need
to use the tripon blue to assess the
viability
you need to be aware that treatment blue
is um
is a toxic and potentially cancerogenic
as well
so if you have any other ways of
counting the cells please do that as
well
uh we do have also automated cell
counter it's called
scepter it's fast and convenient and in
this case
you you take cells directly in the media
so you don't have to
um you don't have to add any drip and
blue
or any other things
there are a number of manipulations you
can do with the cells
once they're growing and once you
achieve a number of cells you need for
downstream applications
we wanted to give you just one of the
examples what you can do with the cells
and that would be transfection as you
know transfection
is a process to introduce dna rna or
protein
into eukaryotic cells and we have two
types of transfection
whether we have a stable transfection or
where we have a
transient transfection the stable
transfection
when the construct which you design the
the which includes the gene of your
interest or protein of your
interest will be integrated into genomic
dna
and it will have a long-term expression
and this application may include protein
production
and generating modal cell lines for drug
discovery for example
the transient transfection
and that in that case there is no
integration in the host genome
it's very short term and usually the
application may include the pathway
analysis
where the long-term expression is not
needed
so when you're planning the transfection
there are a lot of things
we need which you need to take in
consideration
first of all is the method of
transfection
as you know there are different type of
them and it all depends
what are you planning to achieve whether
you want to do the transient
transfection
or where we're talking about stable
transfection
depending also on the cell types the
method is also very important
as you probably know for example the
blood cells
it's almost impossible to transfect them
with anything then
viral vectors so always think about this
what type of cells you're using and what
you're trying to achieve
so the methods we currently have is
either chemical
and one of the most common probably the
lipid-based
transfection there is a physical
transfection like electroporation
viral methods are very popular
especially
when we're talking about stable
transfection because
viruses tend to integrate into
host genome particle-based assays such
as nanoparticles is gold
is also used as well think about the
also the purity
of the construct that can really affect
the quality of transfection and the
efficiency as well
as a amount and the dilution media
if you're working with a crisp
modification they'll absolutely require
the transfection
and it would be very critical what type
of method
you will be using for transfecting the
crispr into the cells
preservation is also a very important
step in your cell culturing and you can
imagine why
the reason to that is that eventually
you would need to take that vial
out of liquid nitrogen and start growing
those soils again
so you need to make sure that you did it
in the correct way and your cells are
in a good quality and viable
now we're at step of cry preservation
and as previously mentioned it is a very
critical step
because eventually if you or your
colleagues will want to use those cells
in a year or two it's it's very
important that the cells which you put
in the freezer
are viable and a good quality as well
it is important to choose your
cryoprotectant
dmso is one of the most common ones but
there are other ones
available as well all depends on your
preferences and also quite
often it's a historical tradition
in the lab as well first
as we mentioned we harvest the cells
and as i showed you before on the on a
gross growth curve we harvest as at the
end of the logarithmic phase because
this is where
the cells are absolutely at their best
resuspend them the media and it is very
important to
count the cells and make sure that you
have an equal amount of cells in each
and every while
please also do put it in your recording
so
even if you leave the lab and someone
new will come they will be able to know
how many cells you have
in that file you would need to
centrifuge it for five minutes to get
rid of
any kind of traces of medium
first and then you resuspend them with
your
cryoprotectant and as i mentioned tmso
is usually one of the most common one
used in the cell lines and they usually
have a formulation of
90 to 10 or 17 to 20 or 10
again it's all depends on your
on your preferences
and then um they pipetted in alico
one milliliter into the into the vials
and start with slow freezing
and usually they use the rate control
freezers like mr frosty usually in the
labs or
any other ones some are using the
more um electronic ones but the
generally the rate should be minus one
to minus three
degrees a minute and
the the slow freezing is very important
because it's important to get rid of any
water
uh left in the cells because it will
otherwise it will turn into the into the
icicles
and will be absolutely harmful for the
cells
once the cells are frozen they can be
transferred into liquid
nitrogen into vapor phase of liquid
nitrogen
and kept there for a very long time
please do
keep all your recordings in order so
people after you would be able to use
those cells
make a proper marking so it's they also
can find
what type of cells is frozen
just to summarize what we talked about
in this presentation
we talk about the cell culture workflow
it is very important to keep ourselves
happy
it's very important to do it
consistently
to achieve reliable and reproducible
information
as we mentioned we start with the sowing
and seeding the cells
feeding them passaging them monitoring
them later on we can either
put them back in the freezer or do
different type of manipulation
expanding them and doing the analysis as
well there are a lot of different type
of analysis i'm not going to go
so much into into that one
you all doing a different um
experiments what i do strongly recommend
you as well to request
our fundamental techniques in the cell
culture it contains
a lot of tips and tricks also protocols
on how to work with the cell culture
it can be very useful for your students
for
for you also to keep in the lab and if
you have any questions
if you need any tricks you can always
find that we do that in collaboration
with the ecac we've been collaborating
with them for
many many years in general if you have
any questions or you need any help
please
do not hesitate to visit our website
contact our specialist we will be more
than happy to help you
with the cell culture workflow
on this i would like to thank you for
joining us on this seminar
and good luck